I remember I've watched your channel
since like pretty much the very first
video you did oh yeah I remember when
your whole thing was being the guy with
the laser a laser guy yeah that was like
your whole thing for a while right that
was fun when you made that did you think
[ __ ] dude I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
making all these videos and become a
YouTuber no that was like one of the
ones where it was like
um just gonna make it for fun it'd be
cool I was in college at the time I was
very sad miserable
um I wanted something to do so I like
college I used like trash and pizza
boxes to make it I used like people
throw away their microwaves so I like
took them apart I would take them from
the dumpster oh my God I got the
Transformer it really didn't do anything
it was like the weight for it
um but yeah it was like made out of
garbage and I did not expect it to do
anything I just wanted to put it
somewhere because I've been watching
YouTube forever so I was like may as
well make one yeah it definitely seemed
like you had Inspirations when you
started yeah yeah I watched a lot of
YouTube yeah who were your inspirations
really
um I don't know I would watch just a lot
of I watched a lot of like filthy Frank
and yeah different shows of course yeah
yeah that was the best time that was the
best time on YouTube ever yeah like I
think it's the best because it's like
it's just like a dude with the [ __ ]
camera and like Mr Beast is cool and
[ __ ] but like he's got like a production
world around him kind of like he's got
like a team of 20 people doing [ __ ] at
all times yeah and like filthy Frank was
just like hey I got that I got that guy
with the camera I'm gonna say some
horribles yeah
he was just a dude in a filthy apartment
yeah yeah that's what I like about it um
I I definitely like that where it's just
like see what one person with a camera
can do is that kind of like the tribe of
the vibe you still try to emulate now
where it's just doing everything oh I
still yeah I mean I I just like to do it
myself because it's like it feels like
more in control right but yeah I don't
do it for any specific purpose yeah like
it would definitely be smarter to like
Outsource it to like like make someone
else edit it or whatever yeah yeah yeah
um but it just like I can't I'm not good
at working in a team either so I can't
like communicate it to them where it's
like this is what I'm going for like I
just like I have to know it and do it
myself right yeah how do you balance
like your YouTube with like your what
you like you know your Twitch offline TV
and everything else then because like if
I was you I would feel like guilty for
not working on my Channel all the time
just because
you like you upload schedule was like so
vast sometimes it is very long in
between yeah not a lot of balance uh I'm
just I'm very lazy sometimes and like
yeah I'll just get like sidetracked
doing like a different hobby you're
trying some other [ __ ] out and I'll be
like oh two months are gone
like I tried to learn a little game
development recently right but it's like
especially if I'm learning something
that's always useful
um yeah not a lot of balance you're
always like leveling up some somehow
hopefully yes yeah hopefully that's how
that's how I feel something yeah exactly
yeah I'm trying to imagine you're like
super productive after doing like five
days of boxing a bit a week as well yeah
that must have like it took a little hit
to the uh productivity
yeah but now that it's off I'm doing a
little more
um
yeah sometimes it's like
I've noticed that like I can see how the
video is like how much [ __ ] I gotta do
for it
um but like
like when I was first starting like I
had no [ __ ] clue how much it was
gonna be but now that I see it all I'm
like [ __ ] what do I do first
um
like I'm unsure of like where to start
sometimes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
uh I mean it's all right I just like try
and do as much as I can every day yeah
fluctuates sometimes it's like 12 hours
sometimes it's throw hours have you
tried to keep like the fitness that you
got during like the boxing period I'm
trying yeah I'm still ahead of the gym
and stuff I still like have a punching
bag in my garage and all that
um I'm trying to keep up with it because
it's nice like right because I that was
like a thing I could work towards I will
never be that fit ever again in my life
I've decided that was my [ __ ] pee
because I had a thing to work towards
and now it's like am I gonna do that for
me no you're not gonna [ __ ] do five
days a week two hours yeah no yeah that
was my so I'm like trying to maintain it
as much as I can right now I mean I
couldn't even do I would I would
definitely relapse to like pizza yeah
yeah relapse mid [ __ ] training we're
like coach food I [ __ ] drive I didn't
even get to the training I'm just like
across and relapse yeah the food the
food was all right let you kind of
burning a lot of calories you're kind of
allowed to eat right a lot which is nice
um
a lot of chicken yeah a lot of chicken a
lot of peppers you know what's one weird
thing that not a lot of people talk
about that is like a preparation for a
fight you're not supposed to nut Is that
real I I could absolutely real I feel
like this is like a thing that boxers
have been doing but there's no and their
coaches have been just like saying I
just yeah I thought it was like a myth
but there's like no scientific proof
that not nutting makes you stronger no
well I I was in the same boat I was
exactly in the same boat okay okay how
long before you're not about enough um
he said like don't do like two weeks two
weeks I was like man I don't know if I
can do two days
and like and I was like like a week I
like I got it to a week and I was like
man [ __ ] this is stupid
I I did and the next day I uh like at
training I was like very lethargic and
he was like No And I was like yeah
and he was like um
I I was like hey is something wrong with
my diet like I I feel like kind of heavy
today do you think it's like something
to do with what I ate and he was like
Hey level with me you know
how the [ __ ] did you know and so that
that it improved a little bit I I don't
know if it's Placebo or a coincidence
but I did not uh up until the fight so
that was yeah yeah and people I haven't
talked to like they were like oh yeah my
coach told me the same thing it's like
something where they like say it and
like maybe try it you should prove it I
don't know I'm just gonna fight at home
yeah I'm not gonna nut I'm in the
control tests
you're telling me that no not November
is actually real
because you really do level up
no not November irritated I mean even
then that's like a benefit
yeah more like aggressive and angry
[ __ ] not right yeah
first punches
that's what the ball guard is for yeah
yeah
you will not not today
yeah I just always thought that was
[ __ ] but I guess yeah maybe there's
some method behind the madness I thought
it was stupid and then had a little
proving so you know who knows was that
was that something that everyone did not
well everyone had a different coach okay
I found a surprising amount of people
were like yeah like Alex was like yeah
my coach told me not to yeah and like a
bunch of other people so it's not just
my coach being a freak and being like
don't do that
I want to see you somehow yeah
thankfully it was everyone I already
tell you [ __ ] anything yeah I know
yeah you'd be like dude do not [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] dude
it will drop your Center
better leverage on punches do you expect
a boxing code I feel like they have more
Authority than any other codes I punch
people dude yeah yeah yeah dude watch Mr
B
you see like how many fighters actually
followed through with that advice
just tell me it's just like the list of
the winners and list of the losers and
just like oh my God it's true
this should be a good scientific study
yeah I think they have done it and
proved that it has no correlation yeah
but also that's in like a controlled
environment so it's hard it must be a
mental thing it must be a mental thing
but I feel like you're holding back so
you're like I don't know maybe your
body's like maybe yeah yeah it's like
something you look forward to after the
fight right but if you go before the
fight then there's nothing to look
forward to what are you doing if you
can't knock yeah the reason why I'm
standing in this ring is because I know
the not afterwards is gonna be the best
knot crazy
bro you're like this fly just end
already so I can just go nuts
bro I'm going for a round one are about
to explore just knock me out dude
oh my God fits right into the trash
taste topics we always talk about
[ __ ] pissing and yeah [ __ ]
pissing and naughty there's no good days
here man I have a banay at my house
because I I learned the truth in Japan
yeah yeah literally yeah it just it
makes pooping just something to look
forward to like Cindy yeah you're like
this is great for me I hate having to
wipe yeah I hate it so I can't I like
yeah and it's just it's just too much
time it's inefficient like now with my
video it's like I [ __ ] and I'm done I'm
quick and you know you're clean and you
know you're good you never get that like
swamp pass later either like yeah just
always like clean yeah it's good I
installed it yeah it's one of my top
three best purchases I've ever made it's
like you like modded you over there at
all I feel like you're the kind of guy
like you know the jet pouched
real quick
yeah I remember londoners tell me all
about us for days oh yeah like how you
got one of the like [ __ ] fanciest
that man knows like the model names
yeah it's like good model I just judged
like in my mind because in Japan you get
to experience all the different levels
of bidet if it opens up and then drives
my ass as well that's how you know it's
like Elite level video yeah yeah that's
like okay [ __ ] this is not playing it's
got a hair dryer built in yeah well your
husband's got a really good one as well
he tore his whole toilet out it was like
the full not just the seat the whole
yeah he told me about this yeah he spent
like 3 000 bucks yeah are you serious
yeah yeah because we were talking about
it and he was like dude it changed my
life
yeah it's like it's got a water warmer
in there and it's like it doesn't feel
that it feels weird like when you first
started yeah like then you're over it
and it's good yeah yeah did you visit to
many uh ryokans when you went to or like
Onsen when you went to Japan no we
didn't visit any you should do that I
think we will I think we're gonna go to
like yeah that's that's one of the
biggest things we recommend when going
to Japan that's also another religious
experience yeah like find a really good
one get that moment where you're like
boys all right we'll all look and we'll
get over it yeah it's like five seconds
honestly honestly now I can't go back
because actually now I stare every time
yeah because like I went to the UK I
went to bathroom which is like a very
like famous spa city in the UK so we
actually like stayed in like a spa hotel
and they had like a they had like a pool
and like hot tubs and public baths there
yeah right
um and then you go in and I've never
felt so unclean going into a public bath
with trunks on I don't know man that's
just I don't know Japan has conditioned
me now to think I need to be [ __ ]
naked to be in like hot water you get
really used to it yeah you do yeah
really fast about like going yeah public
bath to people now like your friends
you're like yeah let's just go yeah
that's whatever you get used to it I
don't know that's cool I like that like
we've all got to do it's like yeah it's
like a bonding moment as well yeah yeah
you don't like specifically look at it
you're just like no it's there you know
yeah it's in my periphery yeah you go
with another content creator you're like
well you know I know that we're
trustworthy because I could just tell
everyone about how big that dick is yeah
yeah you're like oh yeah how big are
their balls yeah I know yeah
when was the last time
oh my God that's pretty cool yeah I
think we do have that in the itinerary
so yeah it's it's a very fun experience
yeah yeah I think we always try and go
to them when we're traveling around
Japan yeah it's just like you get a
really authentic experience of like an
old Japanese woman like forcing you to
eat food that you don't really want to
eat yeah yeah he got woken up he got
like rudely woken up right yeah I had
like there was a real con I went to
where basically the wake-up call for
breakfast is 8 A.M but I got stupidly
drunk the night before yeah right
because it's like a full-on Japanese
meal with like sake and everything so
it's like obviously you're gonna go ham
yeah so I was hung over as [ __ ] because
soccer gives me the worst hangovers and
it's like eight o'clock she's like
knocking on the door she's like calling
the phone it's like oh your breakfast is
ready and I'm like yeah all right [ __ ]
off and then she just the woman just
walks into my hotel room it literally
strips the [ __ ] blanket off me like a
month I was like [ __ ] wake up it's
breakfast and I'm like it's like dude
I'm paying like hundreds of dollars for
you you to do this like this is not this
is not okay because you pay so much
money they like and a lot of the costs
with real cans is like in the food it's
the food yeah and if you don't show up
they get like actually angry yeah
they're like you better [ __ ] show up
and they'll they'll non-stop ringing you
if you're not there yeah oh yeah the
dinner's always amazing but the
breakfast is so 50 50.